[Music]
this is a tomato plant and this is an
aphid slowly killing the tomato plant by
sucking the juice out of its leaves the
tomato is putting up a fight
using both physical and chemical
defenses to repel the attacking insects
but that's not all the tomato is also
releasing compounds that signal nearby
tomato plants to release their own
insect repellant plants are constantly
under attack they face threats ranging
from microscopic fungi and bacteria
small herbivores like aphids
caterpillars and grasshoppers up to
large herbivores like tortoises koalas
and elephants all are looking to devour
plants to access the plentiful nutrients
and water in their leaves stems fruits
and seeds but plants are ready with a
whole series of internal and external
defenses that make them a much less
appealing meal or even a deadly one
plants defenses start at their surface
the bark covering tree trunks is full of
lignin a rigid web of compounds that's
tough to chew and highly impermeable to
pathogens leaves are protected by a waxy
cuticle that deters insects and microbes
some plants go a step further with
painful structures to warn would-be
predators thorns spines and prickles
discourage bigger herbivores to deal
with smaller pests some plant's leaves
have sharp hair like structures called
trichomes the kidney bean plant sports
tiny hooks to stab the feet of bed bugs
and other insects in some species
trichomes also dispense chemical
irritants stinging nettles release a
mixture of histamine and other toxins
that cause pain and inflammation when
touched
for other plant species the pain comes
after an herbivores first bite spinach
kiwi fruit pineapple fuchsia and a
rhubarb all produce microscopic needle
shaped crystals called RAF IDEs they can
cause tiny wounds in the inside of
animals mouths which create entry points
for toxins the mimosa plant has a
strategy designed to prevent verbavoice
from taking a bite at all specialised
Meccano receptor cells detect touch and
shoot an electrical signal through the
leaflet to its base causing cells there
to release charged particles the
build-up of charge draws water out of
these cells and they shrivel pulling the
leaflet closed the folding movement
scares insects away and the shrunken
leaves look less appealing to larger
animals if these external defenses are
breached the plant immune system springs
into action plants don't have a separate
immune system like animals instead every
cell has the ability to detect and
defend against invaders specialized
receptors can recognize molecules that
signal the presence of dangerous
microbes or insects in response the
immune system initiates a battery of
defensive maneuvers to prevent more
pathogens from making their way inside
the waxy cuticle thickens and cell walls
get stronger guard cells seal up pores
in the leaves and if microbes are
devouring one section of the plant those
cells can self-destruct to quarantine
the infection
compounds toxic to microbes and insects
are also produced often tailor-made for
a specific threat many of the plant
molecules that humans have adopted as
drugs medicines and seasonings evolved
as part of plants immune systems because
they're antimicrobial or insecticidal an
area of a plant under attack can alert
other regions using hormones airborne
compounds or even electrical signals
when other parts of the plant detect
these signals they ramp up production of
defensive compounds and for some species
like tomatoes this early warning system
also alerts their neighbors some plants
can even recruit allies to adopt a
strong offense against their would-be
attackers cotton plants under siege by
caterpillars release a specific cocktail
of 10 to 12 chemicals into the air this
mixture attracts parasitic wasps that
lay eggs inside the caterpillars plants
may not be able to flee the scene of an
attack or fight off predators with teeth
and claws
but with sturdy armor a well stocked
chemical Arsenal a neighborhood watch
and cross species alliances a plant
isn't always an easy meal did you know
there's a ted-ed coloring competition
once a month we take select scenes from
your favorite ted-ed animations and we
carefully remove their original coloring
we then invite the ted-ed community to
recolor the illustrations in a friendly
coloring competition hosted on our
patreon page if you're a participants
send us your best work and you might see
it featured on our social media channels
in future ted-ed videos or if we really
like it on our office fridge to learn
more and to support our work please
visit patreon.com slash ted-ed
thanks for watching
[Music]